all next week we're going to be doing  our show from New York City here's the  cool thing here's the coolest part  here's the coolest part we're doing  something we've never done before we'll  be shooting our show at the historic  Apollo Theater in Harlem yeah and let me  tell you something ladies and gentlemen  Harlem is going nut oh my Harlem is like  Conan's coming finally finally  no that's amazing we got some great  guests lined up including louis c.k is  going to come on the show yeah Tracy  Morgan coming on the show Ryan Reynolds  is on the show  dreamy we have some also fun surprise  guests plans so make sure you check out  those shows next week Harlem here we  [Applause]  you